kamo lagence babel et le premier titre
de lecture junior une nouvelle
collection pour les 9-14 ans publié par
gallimard jeunesse sous la conduite de
pierre marchand l'un des éditeurs les
plus inventifs d'aujourd'hui sur la
couverture
superbe pas un mot un dessin seul
illustrait comme des carnets de voyage
imprimés sur des papiers de différentes
couleurs avec des textes de grande
qualité
ce sont des livres souple bon marché
l'auteur de kamo daniel pennac est par
ailleurs en tête des meilleures ventes
aussi bien en poche avec sa petite
marchande de prose que dans les essais
avec comme un roman les illustrations
remarquables sont de jean philip chabot
camo dont le père grand amateur d'art go
est mort de maladie vite avec sa mère
plutôt bon élève il est nul en anglais
comment le convaincre d'apprendre cette
langue
sa mère lui proposa séduisant
subterfuges et sur une trame policière
pennac c'est très intelligemment faire
percevoir à ses lecteurs le bonheur de
l'écriture et de la lecture à travers
des personnages vrais ce livre c'est de
la belle ouvrage